what um what do you think about Wall
Street kind of you know it seems like
turning a corner a little bit and
starting to say from the previous
statement of you know not Bitcoin but
blockchain to now it sounds like
definitely blockchain and maybe Bitcoin
right it's kind of I think where we are
right now where people are saying you
know maybe there is actually some value
to to the digital currency he's got a
deflationary model etc how do you kind
of see that impacting one the currency
and then to kind of you know the future
outlook yeah absolutely I think that
Wall Street is in the business of taking
fees right Wall Street is it's
fundamentally investment banking
commercial banking etc it's it's a
middlemen business it's it's a business
where you have a corporate entity who's
providing a service for clients and
taking a fee for being in the middle of
transactions fundamentally Bitcoin is
about the opposite of that right it's
it's about the ability to trust lessly
disintermediate that process entirely
and conduct frictionless commerce with
two different parties who don't have to
know each other and it's not a surprise
to me that Wall Street has historically
not been receptive to Bitcoin why
they've chose to focus on on sort of
blockchain not Bitcoin I think that
blockchain for Wall Street is actually
something that is fundamentally
nonsensical you know because it's a
close friend of mine morad often likes
to say that block chains don't create
revenues block chains destroy revenues
you know by their very nature if done
correctly they would take away revenues
from the core businesses of many banks
the sort of alternative this alternate
parallel capital market structure that
people are building is actually a
universe where traditional underwriters
and middlemen don't make any money and
you know we're starting to see the
downstream effects of this I see us this
year have financed much and this is
nothing to save the quality of these
icos which is extraordinarily poor but I
cos in aggregate have raised more money
globally than IPOs have in q1 and q2
this year and so I think that there is a
shift and a focus on Bitcoin but I think
that it's more driven by just demand
that they're seeing from high net worth
clients institutional clients about
custody trading Bitcoin about buying it
holding it in their accounts about
providing prime brokerage services
around it I think that some of the more
savvy banks are looking ahead to this
but I don't I don't think the
fundamental attitude has changed I still
see a lot of enterprise blockchain
permission blockchain projects not none
of which have shipped anything of value
I think it's pretty safe to say that to
date and a lot of these efforts have
actually imploded but Wall Street they
were of things that they bring I think
that the capital that comes with Wall
Street is very important in order to
sort of institutionalize Bitcoin as a
real asset class
I think the second really important
thing is that with Wall Street comes a
lot better security tools custody tools
market infrastructure liquidity all of
which is good for all Bitcoin users not
just you know Wall Street I think the
third thing that's really interesting is
that with Bitcoin is going to come you
know Bitcoin on Wall Street is going to
come all sorts of interesting new
financial products some of which I've
been exploring but you know the lowest
hanging fruit is sort of ETFs and
options and other derivatives products
all of which I think helped contribute
to you know bitcoins path as a highly
liquid you know saleable good